There is an idea in Christianity that we have just discussed,
that the judge and the savior are the same person.
Well, you know that in the book of Revelation, you know this or you don't know,
Christ comes back as a judge and he has a sword coming
it's a revealing vision, that book, it's very strange.
It is the last thing you would expect conservative Christians to believe.
And believe me, it's such a visionary hallucination, the book of Revelation.
But Christ returns with a sword that comes out of his mouth and he returns as a judge.
He divides the cursed from the saved.
And most are cursed, some are redeemed. It is very very coarse.
Jung believed that the figure of Christ in the gospels was too pleasant, too merciful,
turned too much to grace, and that referred to an opposing force.
And that was the opposing force of judgment. A very interesting hypothesis.
But then there is the merging of the two ideas,
That the judge and the savior are the same person.
Okay
A young man told me that his life was short
purpose and focus and meaning and that he was nihilistic.
Before he started - he had read the "zen in the Art of Motorcycle Maintenance",
what a book I actually really like.
I have read it three times in three different decades of my life.
And one of the things that is very interesting about the book is that
it is an investigation of the idea of ​​quality, the idea that there is
are qualitative differences between things and that we have the instinct to create qualitative differences.
And so a qualitative difference is simply "This is better than that",
that's a judgment.
Okay, well what Ratzinger suggested is that the person
You know what the modern idea is that you simply have to accept yourself.
-I think that is a bad idea.-
Really, I can't come up with a more nihilistic idea with "You're all right!"
Because, no, you are not!
And the reason that you are not 'ok' is that you can be so much more than you are!
So what do you want to be?
Do you want to stay the way you are or do you want to work towards a better version of yourself?
And this young man, an Australian, he said reason that "Zen and the Art of Motorcycle Maintenance"
such an impact on him was because he was not happy with his current state of well-being.
And he didn't think the way he expressed himself was right.
And the fact that
the author of "Zen", that was Pirsig, had made the remark that you could make qualitative differences.
And that there really is a difference between good things, bad things, good things and bad things.
It gives you a direction.
It gives you the opportunity to move up.
And Ratzinger noted that at least a certain amount
People are not satisfied with themselves and they have to move up.
And so they must conceptualize something of the highest form of "good," and then they must strive for it.
And the thing is that there is no difference between conceptualizing the good and being judged,
because if you start conceptualizing the good and strive for it,
what you have to do is separate yourself from all the things that are not good and you must leave them behind.
And that is why the savior and the judge are the same thing.
And one of the two is very attractive.
I think about the modern world that we reject the existence of qualitative differences.
You say, "Well, we don't want to hurt anyone's feelings by saying that one is better than the other."
And okay, that's reasonable, it's not nice to be cast off with the cursed ones, that's guaranteed.
But if people are not satisfied with their current state,
whatever appears to be the case, try to find someone who is not.
And if you deny that the chance of qualitative differences because you promote radical egalitarianism,
then you also promote the chance of redemption because there is no pursuit of the good.
And it seems to me that it is catastrophic to sacrifice good for
Well, it is catastrophic to sacrifice the good for the same.
Because if we were all equal,
then we would all be just as free and miserable.
And thus..
*applause*